this morning president donald trump left
las vegas for arizona
after a weekend of campaigning around
nevada in arizona president trump does
have some ground to make up
democratic presidential nominee joe
biden leads the latest cbs news
battleground tracker poll campaigning in
carson city on sunday
president trump told the mostly maskless
audience a biden presidency would lead
to a
a grinch-like lockdown he mocked the
former vice president for wanting to
listen to scientists about the pandemic
christmas season will be canceled look
remember i said we're going to bring
back christmas right the name
remember we brought it back he'll listen
to the scientists
if i listen totally to the scientists we
would right now have a country that
would be in a massive
depression in response the biden
campaign blamed president trump for the
failing economy
and not listening to scientists biden
steps off the campaign trail today to
focus on preparing for this week's final
presidential debate